John Douglas is known as the man who
paints rock and roll and he also
performs it John is the current drummer
for Aerosmith and his artwork is now on
display at an amazing Gallery at the
Venetian Resorts welcome to the show
thanks so much JC pleasure to be here
you have a gift my friend it is a gift
thank you very much
um
it's what I love to do though when did
you when did you realize you can paint
such beautiful pieces of art uh about
two minutes ago when I showed up here no
I think it really was until 8th grade
until my eighth grade art teacher saw
before that I couldn't stay in the lines
and I didn't get any recognition from
any art teacher but eighth grade was a
pivotal teacher for me which is why
teachers are so important
and I think it's great too for kids out
there who can't who campaign who can't
stay in the lines look what you can
accomplish with your work don't let that
stop you from uh you know pursuing a
pursuing art uh when do you when do you
paint when do you find time to paint
you're drumming with Aerosmith yeah I
paint uh there's so much down time when
you tour and uh that's how I occupy my
time I go into a hotel room and I look
for a blank wall and I
tape or push pin or whatever a campus on
a hotel wall and that's how I occupy my
time and I've been doing it for years
and it they add up oh they certainly do
what was the first painting that you did
because you're if you've been to a Hard
Rock Hotel Hard Rock Cafe if you picked
up any a music magazine your artwork is
all over the place but who is the first
person that you did
yay
I mean I I we're talking like when I was
a kid yeah I always like to paint or
draw at first it was drawing these are
paintings I would draw my favorite and I
was always into music so I can remember
drawing a a queen I can remember drawing
Aerosmith oddly enough uh uh so it's
always kind of been because my passion
is music when I would do art it was
always kind of music and my teachers
would say I have a one-track mind and
I'd say oh it's an eight-track that's
how it tells you how old I am music
driver yeah but so when you do a review
it's obviously a pretty Mercury you got
Elvis the Eddie Van Halen is just and
what a tribute to Eddie Van Halen uh
Stevie Nicks yeah and then you have you
have Stephen Tyler as well when you do a
reveal to someone what is there pressure
when you show the show the musician for
the first time like look what I did
what's that feeling like yeah I mean
it's when you're uh working for somebody
it's not always smart to paint a picture
of them because if they don't like it
you know so and I don't always do that
uh but uh fortunately most of the time
they love it and they're they're
flattered and a lot of times they'll
they'll sign it like that that of
Stephen
oh my gosh you know I've worked for Van
Halen for 25 years you know so I have
some at home that had signed for me um
Elvis it's tough to get him to sign
anything it's really hard yeah no they
stayed maybe at some Island somewhere he
could be you know we find them uh how do
you know Aerosmith things so you were
drumming for Aerosmith last year during
The Residency he performed them at the
Grammys how did that come together
um well Joey Kramer has been the drummer
for Aerosmith forever and uh he got
injured uh the day of the show here in
Vegas and I got the phone call and uh I
don't remember whether they told me or
they asked me but either way you're
ready I did it you know and um and then
here I am yeah we have some Vegas
connections too because you have the
gallery on display with the Venetian
right now opens tonight and yeah you can
come see your artwork but you also have
a connection with a legion Stadium yeah
um I got a call from uh
artist Michael Goddard
during the light right during the
lockdown to paint the Beatles for the
Allegiant Stadium there's a bunch of Art
in there I don't know if you've been
there yeah it's a great Stadium but so
they he curated this huge art collection
and all kind of centered around Las
Vegas and the Beatles played Vegas in
64. and so I was asked to commemorate
that so I did four individual paintings
of them and then it's hanging in some
high roller Suite up there somewhere and
then I got last year I got asked to
paint
um
[Music]
yeah they got inducted into the NFL Hall
of Fame so yeah so I've got more art
hanging in there and it's an honor
because it's a beautiful beautiful
Stadium which I think it's an honor for
the players too to have you paint them
because your work is it's legendary what
can we expect tonight at the Venetian at
the ground Grand Canal shops uh yeah at
the at the animation Gallery
um the paintings are all hung there uh
all week I'll be there tonight between
six and nine uh just kind of hanging out
talking to people that want to talk
about rock and roll or art or both and
uh from six to nine and then tomorrow is
a big VIP red carpet event with uh one
of Gene Simmons I love that one there'll
be some special people there I think my
buddy's from ZZ Top who are playing at
the Venetian they're gonna pop by
beautiful uh for tomorrow's a VIP thing
and um probably hopefully a couple guys
from Aerosmith will pop by if they're
still in town yeah and uh it's gonna be
a good time last question you and I were
talking about this where we started
you're painting that Eddie Van Halen and
you're you're almost done do you ever
stop and restart or once you start once
you start painting you're in the flow
and you keep going
there I mean there are times where you
know yeah
especially when it's a blank canvas they
have that you're like oh do I can I do
this anymore but then there are times
when I get in it that you know I I does
it look like them and I take pictures
all along and and but but it's not done
until I say it's done yeah you know and
thankfully most of the time nobody's
seeing the process but me and so uh I
just keep working it until I think it's
done and and that's the keys like how do
you know when you're done uh
you never know it's gamble yeah but
amazing work beautiful well thank you
John thank you so much for joining us
our work on display at the Venetian
thank you so much Las Vegas now we will
be right back